yo homie I asked you a bunch of
questions I wanna have them answered
immediately what a story mark what are
the things I wanted to talk about was
like how old were we when we for it when
we got our first job I was 14 and that's
pretty early because usually around here
you have to be 16 I don't know what the
law is for other states for sure but in
Ohio it was 16 you could just go
anywhere and apply for a job unless they
wanted you to be 18 or over for them for
the job but in my case I had to go to
the principal of my school at middle
school and get a work permit which meant
that I had to have good grades good
attendance and the principal would sign
something that meant that at age 14 I
could get a job somewhere so my first
job was working as a custodian at a
truck parts warehouse because my dad
worked there and he talked to his boss
and was like hey my son would like some
extra money I know you're looking for a
custodian he's only 14 he'll clean the
place well love applause so that was
literally probably the hardest job my
whole life well why is that well first
it was my first job so obviously there's
like like a realization like you're
getting smacked in the face with oh this
is life you work really hard for money
ya mean the boy exactly yeah it
was terrible because I was the only
custodian and it was a giant truck parts
warehouse so there was oil and grease
and dust and just filth over the floors
and the walls and it was like it had
caked onto the walls so much that I'm
pretty sure the owners of this facility
just assumed that was the decor
that's the paint scheme yes and so I
remember one day I think I think I
worked five or six hours a day because
there was super part time there was like
a limitation to how much a
fourteen-year-old could actually how
many hours of 14 year old could actually
work and I remember I spent an entire
day on just one there one room of
shelving and parts and I cleaned half of
in a day and what did you learn from
this I learned that that money doesn't
come by easy I learned that when I fit
down and just gotta keep getting
back up and you kind of gotta roll with
the punches well yeah exactly yeah so it
really taught you I should probably make
youtube videos for her for a career one
day yeah at age 14 I was like whenever
YouTube gets invented that's what I
should look at I always every single day
that I worked there I had to get a new a
new change of clothes cuz they didn't
even provide me with a uniform you're
just coming in there and you're graphic
tees and your job is my old t-shirts and
my jeans and I would leave and there
would be oil stains on my pants and
stuff and it would be like a new change
of clothes and I got paid minimum wage
which at the time was five dollars and
fifteen cents an hour
I remember those days yeah and so
basically I went in there worked for
five hours got $25 and then with that
$25 bought a new pair of clothes to wear
next side you come back and just grease
them up yeah so that was my first job
what was your first job I got a
multitude of judge yeah I want to talk
about my other jobs too okay tell me
your first well my first job was
probably the worst job you could ever
wish on anyone I worked at a nursing
home but I worked in the dishwashing
room of a kitchen of a nursing home I
did not know this really it's something
I took way deep down inside and old
people like eat soft food but when they
eat they leave a lot of residue on the
plate oh no amongst other things
and I remember washing the dishes and I
wasn't very good at it either a lot of
complaints about how I left
oatmeal or applesauce once again eat
soft things
Yeah right they don't chew they just
swallow
[Laughter]
so yeah I remember doing that for about
three months and then I just I didn't
quit I just stopped going so I think I
got fired somewhere in there okay you
know you know what it was there here's
how old here's how pathetic I am this is
two thousand four or five maybe three I
don't remember I remember School of Rock
starring Jack Black was coming out at
midnight on a Thursday I blew up work so
I could go watch that movie amazing and
I think I got fired because of school
rock I'm anything so there was a good
movie well it wasn't
I liked School of Rock it was what a
jack wax better movie yeah we'll say
that I like school yeah so did you ever
find any dentures on the plate you know
yeah I got to the point where I just
stopped cleaning I just throw them in
the dishwasher didn't look back yeah
well yeah those are some crappy first
jobs after after the truck parts
warehouse I progressed on to a fantastic
five-star restaurant known as Taco Bell
oh yeah chalupa yeah and it was a taco
bell/pizza hut combination back when
those used to exist around here so I did
both I would make tacos and I would make
pizza primarily though I made pizza at
Pizza the Pizza Hut side of it and I
still have terrible memories of my
horrific the awful manager who was
definitely not suited for the position
he I guess that when I as soon as I came
in the previous manager had quit and
this basically his runner-up was looks
over the job was it some kid oh yeah
okay he was young he was only a couple
years older than me it was horrible did
you ever make tacos at the talk yeah a
little bit it was mostly pepper it was
mostly the pepperoni pizzas but yeah I
would make tacos from time to time it
was that was just a seasonal job during
the summer the force you know what
school was out yeah
awful awful job again obviously minimum
wage no respect you got free Taco Bell
every day I guess was something but I
mean even that just means I'm gonna be
on the all night yeah the
question is would you rather have free
Taco Bell or free Pizza Hut
I see that's the question that is a big
moral dilemma yeah that's that's the
conflict in this story I think it
depends on what mood I was in how how
much I wanted to do that night
or how less I want how much
less I wanted to do
that was my second job do you member
yours oh yeah okay so I actually was an
upper bay technician at Jiffy Lube and
if you went to Jiffy Lube in around 2006
I probably up your car it was
awful we weren't trained my friend
actually worked as a lower Bay
technician so he would drain the oil I
remember the first day I was there my
friend didn't know what he was doing I
didn't know what I was doing he actually
drained the transmission fluid instead
of the oil and we overfilled the oil so
this car left with no transmission fluid
and ten quarts of oil so I worked there
for a few months
we broke a lot of things accidentally
and I now know how to change my oil
though so that's good yeah well after
Taco Bell I progressed on to a very
well-known American establishment called
Walmart and I think just getting up I
know I worked
Sylla teenager and Walmart was possibly
worse than Taco Bell because the store
supervisor who worked there he was the
biggest asshole ever why's that
he would discipline employees in public
in front of the customers like if they
messed up anything he would very loudly
like scold you in front of cuff supid
yeah like there was this it was my
second or third day on the job and I
stalked something improperly I did not
know how to do it perfectly I was
learning and he took me aside in front
of customers and like quite literally
wagged his finger in my face like
telling me everything I did wrong and I
remember I only stayed there for a
couple more weeks after that because I
just I couldn't deal with his pressure
what what did you do specifically
stopped III stock something
the wrong place okay well the item was
in the wrong location how dare you Chris
I know I'm not Walmart material get the
out and they're really hot I really
had not Walmart material according to
that guy that's for sure didn't stay
there very long I gave him a two-week
notice and everything and I was like I
can't be here Baba but after that I
worked at a supermarket called marks
that's around here and I was a cashier
and the stock guy I've always thrown my
all my teenage years I did I've done all
the grind you know I've done this
fast-food I've done the cashier I've
done the retail trim and I and I had
enough of those experiences to no I
don't want to do that for the rest of my
life right back yeah yeah I understand I
worked at Hollister the clothing store
in the mall for about two months once
and I had to wear jeans and like polos
and they wanted me to go tanning and
flip-flops and I remember just standing
around folding clothes all day and they
wanted me to do inventory and count all
the clothes and you know I'm not a
mathematician Chris so I I just started
making up numbers I figured it would
even itself out and then when I was
about 2,000 off they came over and fired
me on the spot
whose house yeah like women's crop tops
I don't know what I was doing but I got
fired from there too that's Gary's yeah
my first I worked at McDonald's
also after marks whoa just a slew man I
worked in Donald's third shift okay
24 hour McDonald's and I all I did all
night was make hundreds of thousands of
breakfast burritos to stock them in the
fridge so they could heat them up in the
morning and I cleaned the fry machine
every night Wow which made me not need
french fries for like like a year it
just disgusted you that much the grease
and the the stains oh my god it
was a trout I still have the smell in my
in my in my brain of like the scent of
the McDonald's sink the water and sludge
and I'm so combined with fry grease and
burger grease it turned me off of any
type of food like that for a very
long time really I'll hunt your dreams I
know it does hi
I delivered pizzas for four or five
years of my life I think that's when we
met yeah we did I
sounds fun yes it was magical yes your
honor pizza to my door sign fighted you
in when blue in the birds flew in after
me and no I pizza and Papa John's but I
will say this those are some delivering
pizzas is the most enjoyable therapeutic
job I ever had you can have privacy you
get in your car you listen to music if
you want to steal a pizza from the store
you put it in your car eat it on the way
you can do that you get good tunes
playing it's it's just a good time you
get up there you deliver the pizza and
you just get back in your car and you go
back it's so good yeah that sounds fun
that that's that's definitely better
gonna pull over and take a nap
pull over take it at your choice all
their pizzas are getting cold who cares
yeah you know the people who don't tip
you kind of just put them on the bottom
and exactly yeah still a pepperoni off
of it or two and man you get a call
excuse me my pizza has a bite taken out
yeah I almost died a few times though
really yeah there was one time I went to
a crackhead meth motel oh my god and the
lady answered the door and we I just
knew it wasn't gonna be good and she
started like crying she had like meth
sores all over her face oh she was like
coming in come in my baby's getting cold
my baby's getting cold
my baby's kidding there was no baby and
I took a step into the room and I looked
through the crack of the door there's a
big dude behind the door like waiting
for me to walk in my and I just turned
around I was like I'm good
and then so yeah yeah it's it's kind of
a dangerous job but I liked the thrill
of it I that make I want to make that
scene in a movie yeah it's a guy who
realizes there's some big-ass dude right
behind the door is about to kill
him yeah and that could like I want that
movie to be made like make Nightcrawler
meets Pizza Delivery yeah that's what I
need the sociopathic pizza delivery man
I'll do it yeah yeah you'll be good at
my first real job I guess you could say
let that actually felt like it could
lead somewhere I was
looking for Akron public schools for two
years this was after McDonald's and I
worked on buses with kids who were like
in the orthopedic route they had some
sort of physical disability or a mental
disability of some kind and they needed
basically like a helper person where if
something happened I could immediately
attend to it like sometimes a child
would throw up or they might you know go
to the bathroom and yeah so that that
aspect wasn't fun okay like the cleaning
up parts that was not the best part but
a lot of those kids really were actually
really cool like they actually
really liked me and and one of the tough
conversations and I felt like I was
actually doing something good like I was
making them happy opens up your eyes a
little bit it does yeah and I made them
smile before they went to school because
I'm sure school was not fun for them
sure yeah and so it felt like that I did
that for two years
and that was not much money at all ever
I think it was like eight bucks an hour
but it was it was better than McDonald's
that's for sure so and then my last job
before I finally said screw this I'm
doing I'm gonna do this movie thing
full-time I sold newspapers Wow I was a
newspaper salesman like telemarketing no
I doing a door I was the guy when you go
to a mall or to a store and there's
somebody standing there behind a
newspaper counter like literally trying
to solicit every customer for a
newspaper sooner newspapers newspapers
exactly exactly okay that was horrible
because it was entirely commissioned so
there was one day where I worked for
eight hours newspapers don't cost too
much they don't know but I mean if you
got subscriptions signed up okay then
you got money there was one day where I
worked for eight hours and I made $200
and it was great great yeah I made all
these subscriptions I was on fire people
were ordering newspaper subscriptions
not just Sunday delivery they wanted
seven-day delivery and you did it and I
got those people to sign up for
the Akron Beacon Journal goddamn it
but then there was a day where I worked
for almost ten hours made $20 Wow and I
said that very day I went never again
I'm never doing this again and that's
when I decided to do the movie thing
full-time okay and I was 24
so I basically from age 14 to 24 for a
decade really
I worked regular jobs and tried to
figure out what I wanted to do I always
knew I wanted to be involved in movies
but until YouTube kind of came around
and gave you sort of an outlet for like
the normal everyday guy from Ohio or in
your case Indiana mm-hmm to put your
voice out there the entertainment world
was like this impenetrable thing like
how do I do that you have to just be
like it has to be magic you have to be
in LA and bump into somebody and then
suddenly you're a person and now it's
different like you can if you make good
stuff and put it out you can actually
get noticed no yeah I agree I I always
thought public public access videos were
the future in high school I was like
that's how I'm gonna get known yeah yes
with John flicking - yeah exactly I mean
I yeah a few other jobs real quick I
worked at a call center for a cell phone
company I worked at a marketing company
and a cubicle all day and I remember
that job I used to look out the window
and watch the guy in mow the grass and
think I would give anything to be that
guy right now because they're not in a
cubicle yeah exactly I was also an usher
at a movie theater and if that job would
pay really good I would do that every
day cuz it's yeah you get to go clean a
theater and you know sometimes they were
I would go watch me I remember watching
Avatar like two times in one day and I'd
hear the walkie-talkie John popcorn
spill Niall oh yeah I'll be right there
and I'm like watching Jake Sully climb
the tree of life and a woman that was a
fun job but yeah right back at you I am
I remember doing YouTube part-time or
kind of just for fun during that that
time in my life and then one day you
know kind of took off but good times
yeah finally